you guys a date my hair run Kim
Kardashian looks ravishing in red hair
that is to love it oh we love it
I was sitting there and I was like why
not the 39 year old reality star debuted
her new summer do a nice shade of
fire-engine red to her Instagram stories
Monday in a series of selfie videos
first rocking a low pony and then up it
went into a sassy messy bun a change up
in Kim's look comes after months of
keeping her brunette locks pretty much
the same as she self isolates amid the
corona virus outbreak kim's played with
many different hairstyles over the years
from her oh gee brunette - platinum
blonde and we can't forget this pink
moment while she was traveling in japan
- rocking a few grey blond looks both
short and long I wanted to get that
message out there
Amen sista the beauty mogul isn't the
only one showing off a new do Kim's
sister Kylie Jenner has been showing off
her baby pink locks on Instagram shortly
after Kim changed it up while their
sister Khloe rung in her 36th birthday
as a brunette usually blonde bombshell
shared these sultry shots pre birthday
bash and captioned the pics in part I'm
loving my brown hair I never thought I
would say that lol blonde still owns my
heart but this brown is giving me a
little something right now and we
couldn't agree more
[Music]